speaking of 2020 we have really big news
in the 2020 Democratic primary there's a
big shake-up that's taking place it's
been about a week since we looked at
polling numbers and my question last
week was when should the can that it's
polling zero and one get out of the
twenty twenty Democratic primary most of
you said that they should get out now or
very soon we now have a shake up Joe
Biden is still in the lead but that lead
is increasingly smaller and smaller and
it is now Elizabeth Warren who for the
first time in this entire primary hasn't
surged into second place she has passed
Bernie Sanders and she has passed Kamala
Harris these are small changes okay
Bernie and Kamala slightly down and
Elizabeth Warren slightly up but the
trend is clear and the trend has been
that Elizabeth Warren has had a
trajectory that has sort of been immune
from the ups and downs of other
candidates lots of candidates have had
big ups and downs Elizabeth Warren
hasn't had that as you see on your
screen Elizabeth Warren has had a slow
steady climb about 1.5 points per month
dating back to April and she is now
within the margin of error but in second
place averaging 16 point 3 percent of
the vote now in the meantime she's been
helped a little bit by the facts that
Bernie and Kamala Harris have had sort
of some weak results in recent polls one
by the NBC by NBC Wall Street Journal
another by The Economist and one by
Emerson so important data points first
of all Bernie Warren and Harris are
still really close there's only two
points in total separating the three of
them important to keep that in mind
these are small changes that we're
seeing another note the distance between
the top four and everybody else is
getting bigger and bigger the top four
now holds almost 73 percent of the vote
16 other candidates are splitting the
remaining 27 percent of the vote so no
one seems to have any chance of even
getting into the top four other than
maybe Pete Buddha judge who's still at
six percent I believe at this point that
everybody below Buddha judge is done
many of them will drop out after the
debate that's happening in a couple of
weeks and we'll be covering covering
that debate live for you
course in the meantime the decline of
Joe Biden continues to be something to
behold at one point Joe Biden had a lead
of almost 27 points over Bernie Sanders
in early May
Biden's lead has shrunk shrunk shrunk to
just nine over Elizabeth Warren at this
point and it is a very different race
now than it was when Joe Biden first got
into this thing and between Joe Biden's
poor debate performance and some of
these strange public appearances
combined honestly with a relatively
small public profile other than showing
up in Seattle a couple days after the
debate and saying something very weird
about a gay waiter which I talked about
so at some point and I've gotten
questions about this there is going to
be the issue of our Bernie and Warren
splitting enough of the vote that
combined they could take the lead over
Joe Biden so like as an example right
now Elizabeth Warren is polling 16 and
Bernie's polling 15 if we imagine that
80% of Bernie voters would switch to
Warren if Bernie was out I'm not saying
those are the numbers but imagine that
that was the case that would put Warren
at 28 and Warren would now be tied with
Joe Biden - presumably some portion of
Bernie's supporters would switch to
Biden rather than Elizabeth Warren so
let's do it in Reverse these are
hypotheticals I don't want to anger
anybody imagine that if Elizabeth Warren
got out 80% of her supporters said I'm
switching to Bernie that would also put
Bernie in a virtual tie with Joe Biden
again Biden would probably pick up a
point or two from Warren getting out as
well I still don't believe that we need
to worry about this right now it's early
we haven't had a second debate there are
people who are going to drop out we are
going to see more of that 100 percent
total realign behind the candidates that
remain in we'll get to that third debate
in September probably only on one stage
at that point there will be few enough
candidates so let's continue to focus on
issues let's not allow in particular as
I said at the top of the show don't
allow Trump to play games to divide the
left this entire Trump taking Pelosi
side against the progressive new Dems
it's it's meant to divide the left don't
allow it to happen
let's go through the process let's
support the candidate that we believe
represents our values and shares our
policy positions and let's go from there
don't fall into this other stuff the
polling is going to take care of itself
let's continue to advocate to make sure
everybody who wants to vote is going to
have their vote counted both in the
primary and in November of 2020 let's
continue to ensure that the DNC or try
to ensure that the DNC does not put
their fingers on the scale or their leg
on the scale or their entire body on the
scale and we have the closest thing to
an open and fair primary as possible and
then we'll deal with Harris I'm sorry
with Warren and Bernie potentially
splitting the progressive electorate to
Joe Biden's advantage we will deal with
that when the time comes for it if you
think the time is now then I want to
hear from you okay let us know we're on
instagram at david pakman show and the
show is on instagram at david pakman